Welcome to our first state of play of
2023. we've got a lot to show you
including an in-depth demo of Suicide
Squad kill the Justice League but first
PlayStation VR2 is finally here let's
Dive Right In with a look at five games
arriving on Playstation VR2 this year
let's see how you do this time
kid we gotta work on your focus
jail they'll get you killed out there
remember what we shook on or
I guess we'll just have to keep this up
let's try again
[Music]
everything
throughout the world
[Music]
all your weapons now
thank you
[Music]
man come in please
I need you
[Music]
foreign
this may be hard to hear
the Empire will fall
our galaxy will be plunged into thirty
thousand years of chaos and War thank
you for saving us
but there is a plan to save Humanity
[Music]
so will you fight for a dying Empire
or help us
to reach Foundation
[Music]
you see that tower out there big scary
one
that's where I'm taking you to
skatekeeper
to be judged
your life you're gonna show it to me
think back to the very beginning the
first thing that you can remember
every time you blink you're going to
jump forward in time
hey you come over here
is that really you it it's Chloe your
neighbor
only way to fight against time is to
create a work of Genius which might live
on after you're gone
foreign
[Music]
you're ashamed of something something so
terrible you're trying to Blink right
past it
[Applause]
now the next time that you blink I'm
gonna send you back
and just try to enjoy it this time
[Music]
that was a sneak peek at some great
upcoming games for PlayStation VR2
up next Bungie gives us a stunning new
look at Destiny 2 lightfall which
Launches on PS5 next week
[Music]
what is that
the witness
the male effector of our first collapse
visit our doorstep
here I have no purpose nervous because
you fear to seek honest
is your failure
then God will use keep the enemy away
from the traveler at all costs
not all of us have lives to spare
your fear brings you pain
we know pain
[Music]
the battle begins here and the now
foreign
[Music]
how many nations
together
[Music]
Chia is one of our most anticipated
games and it's launching into the
Playstation Plus game catalog in March
speaking of PlayStation Plus let's take
a look at what's in store next month
[Music]
our next game is from enhance the
creators of Tetris effect and res
infinite
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
la la
[Music]
what's up
so big day class president's speech at
the assembly in light of the whole Space
Rock potential demise of civilization
thing My Chosen theme feels off what's
the theme using this year to make an
impact yeah yeah perfect go with that
are you okay you've come into this year
kind of intense with the band stuff the
band is important
why did she have to just leave I said it
was an emergency you did and it is to
you
[Music]
it's weird how everyone's acting like
nothing is different
but to me Everything feels different now
we always done what you wanted to do and
that's fine but there's only so much
time we have left how are we supposed to
just be fine
[Music]
I'm not gonna lose you hear me now I'll
just cut you off completely
I'll inherit my Master's will
you can't defeat me
no matter what you become I Will Always
Love You the Hokage is the person who
walks in front of everyone and Bears all
the pain
because we're friends
but here we go
in a Flash huh my blood is boiling
charge no despair you can't escape how
about this
don't underestimate the will a fight
I'll settle this now is the hour of
judgment
this is
prepare yourself sweet dreams how about
this you'll be eaten alive
from here for US History will be spun
again and so began their Journey
on a path with no end
with his power I will establish perfect
order what you describe is nothing more
than oppression through force and fear
my frail little brother no
I do not wish to fight you elder brother
captivating fantasy worlds await in our
next two games
tell you a story
true
my life
mattled piece by piece
and when I tried to buy it back it cost
me everything
I must finish what I started
death's design will be
discovered secret
find out what it is that makes him
invincible so we can strip him off his
advantage
[Music]
you're upon a slave to forces you cannot
comprehend
Catherine is a frightening man but you
have something he doesn't allies worth
having together we will strike down the
absolute
foreign
welcome to wayfinder an online
multiplayer adventure for you and your
friends it's all set in evinor a
gorgeous but Fallen World
you'll Control the Chaos through
wayfinders
senja who likes to get up close and
personal and Silent who fights with both
Firepower and fast reflexes
[Music]
the windrave slices through The Fray
while also supporting the group
booked another Victory under our belts
let's head to Skylight our Social Hub
here you'll turn your loot into new
weapons and wayfinders you can also
explore dungeons called Lost zones the
modify and mutate for a greater
challenge
boss zones are for you and your friends
will team up to complete quests collect
Loot and Hunt bosses like this Titan
[Music]
we're excited to bring wayfinders beta
exclusively to PlayStation and you can
sign up for the chance to play early and
now
now thanks for watching
we've got big updates on two highly
anticipated Capcom games starting with
the debut of three new characters for
Street Fighter 6.
foreign
[Music]
brace yourself
serious
is your last blind let's go
foreign
[Music]
for you
only I can hear it
but not the one we're looking for
[Music]
foreign
another mission awaits
[Music]
you see we are all connected through the
holy body
when you need only accept the sacred
gift
Christ like
she did
Temperance child
I've taken delivery of preparing some
entertainment for you ah the
entertainment without further adapters
the gallon night perfects the princess
fan
I'm making cheek for you move
star was like this with you how about
you open fire instead of your mouth
long time no see Richard krauser why
you can't save her
you can't save anyone
gonna happen with me you gotta keep
moving forward we will beat this
together
let us rescue the princess you gotta
hurt yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
this time
it has to be different
[Music]
it will now time to call some Mayhem
the show's not over yet it's Harley
Quinn Deadshot king shark and Captain
Boomerang against the world's greatest
DC superheroes in this extended look at
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
let's hear from developer Rocksteady
Studios foreign
my name is Darius cedarian and I'm the
studio product director at Rocksteady
Studios Suicide Squad killed the Justice
League is the next installment in the
Arkham verse and we'll be releasing this
may
it is a third person action shooter set
five years after the events of Batman
Arkham Knight
Metropolis has been invaded and you're
going in as The Suicide Squad members
Harley Quinn King sharp Deadshot and
Captain Boomerang to face off against
the ultimate threat a corrupted Justice
League
the team has been hard at work at
creating the best possible game
experience for our players and we're
very excited to share more as part of
this state of play today let's take a
brief look at one of the missions in our
game The Flash has been corrupted by
brainier and as The Suicide Squad you'll
need to work together in up to four
player online co-op to stop the Flash
and rescue Lex Luthor in the process
enjoy
thank you
oh you know what
hold on a sec hello Brainiac
is it happening now
great you will have Luther ASAP
good news
you want Luther all you have to do is
what the hell was that flash is alive
and he has Luther one damn thing at a
time
[Music]
if there's a snowball's chance in hell
you can destroy it I expect you to no
matter the cost are we clear
yeah where the snowball
time to light them all up
out
of my way
guys let's dance
oh
that's gonna leave a mark
yeah focus on fire on this tank why do
we never get reinforcements
love explosions
[Music]
house
incoming
Roger that Quinn
[Music]
hi come we got more company go start go
senseless violence love it
feel that weak spot Squad no worries
Boomer
just call me the Pinball Wizard
Unstoppable
thank you
all ready
ouch I love our escapades
thank you
though how the whole taking down the
flash thing go
she's still in play let me get out of my
way I have work to do
good
well hey there sleepyhead we've got an
interrogation to get back to
[Music]
Gonna Let You you walk away
everything you know
[Music]
you think they can stop us
pathetic
at least I'm not a big hero turns stooge
for a space man
okay boomerang
you want to see what a real hero can do
I'll show you
flash how do I stop this
please tell me how
[Music]
you have to kill us Diana
we have to die
save the world
[Music]
Suicide Squad killed the Justice League
arrives on PS5 May 26th
Rocksteady Studios has even more to
share today let's listen in
show me what you got
laughs
Suicide Squad killed Justice League is
an extension of the Arkham verse and
it's really about now reframing the
story and telling it from the villain's
point of view where are we going and who
are we killing it's a mixture of lots of
the things I hope the fans like about
Rocksteady but like a whole massive
chunk of new stuff that they've never
seen before
always seen Batman's perspective on this
world and we thought it'd be really fun
and enjoyable to see this universe but
Through The Eyes of the villains
a story five years after the end of
Arkham Knight and A lot's changed in
that time just checking we're all seeing
that thing right Brainiac has invaded
Earth and he's this huge threat
overlooking Metropolis he's taken over
Metropolis City the Justice League are
there to try and save the city but
Brainiac has captured and brainwashed
them and turned them against the very
people they've been sworn to protect oh
[__] Superman
so the Justice League share the same
goal as a brainiac to take over Earth
and turn it into the nucleus what we've
created is a classic Justice League but
with the sense that there's something
wrong with them they are now doing
brainiacs bidding and Amanda Waller
scrambles to try to remedy this and
essentially save the Earth and she
recruits for lovable characters into
fighting the Justice League in an effort
to reclaim the Earth and thwartz
brainiac's plans your new mission is to
kill the Justice League the members of
The Suicide Squad are Harley Quinn
Captain Boomerang Deadshot and king
shark Harley Quinn is definitely the
most acrobatic of the cruise she's
always moving she's always flying
through the air and kind of barely
controlled ways the feeling of swinging
and the momentum and the kind of
physicality of it and trying to keep
that momentum going and use that to go
over buildings or swing under bridges
and shine that into kind of the grapple
mechanic that she's got it just feels
it's got on
I'm a freaking super star
Deadshot has the iconic Deadshot look
but with a rock steady twist he's got a
real Swagger to him and in this game he
can also hover with his jet pack he's
super precise he uses sniper rifles
assault rifles and pistols and they all
fit with his sort of the fantasy of
playing as Deadshot as this master
assassin are you on team waller or team
get the hell out of this mess King shop
to me as as a person is well as a fish
is this incredible character who's super
well read and super well to do and I'm
sure could smash an operatic performance
actually I'm the son of a god
is my shame to suffer Mortals in their
buffoonery but also doesn't really know
simple words or simple things that are
going on I think that's brilliant in
terms of combat he is a brute he's a
tank character he can take more damage
his abilities all lean into the fact
that he wants to get in a bit more close
and personal he's the fastest no a
character
Captain boomerang's got his speed force
Gauntlet that he can use together with
his boomerang he can throw it to any
point in space and speed force to that
point along the walls along the floor
and get wherever he wants to go you can
use that get up close Dodge around in
midair taking out the enemies and then
Scarpa because he doesn't want to stick
around don't worry guys I'm here one of
the most exciting parts that connects
our game to the DC lore are the support
Squad piss off Widow and you have
penguin the arm stealer you're making
guns for us now bird brain but also some
new faces pack who is a digital ghost
that is helping the squad both navigate
the world but also upgrade their neck
bombs that's a big adrenaline Spike on a
nice bomb sending out this toy man who's
helping the squad with perfecting gear
and then finally we have Gizmo who is
helping the squad with insane vehicle
Creations that let you blow [__] up
Metropolis is your playground you're
going to get to meet different
characters different villains and you
really get to see these cool iconic
locations being the city of Tomorrow
kind of like meant stark contrast with
Gotham City which is very dirty it's
always raining and that contrasts with
like a city that's very Grand it's very
clean it's very functional the huge
difference between metropolis and Gotham
is that Metropolis really acknowledge
and really trust Superman so there's a
lot of statues to thank Superman for
everything he's done for the city you're
getting to see Metropolis through the
villain's eyes you're going to
experience this world and Traverse view
this world as the villains
Metropolis to the core ability that
everything wraps around in Suicide Squad
is your traversal how that works with
combat is you're chaining your combat
moves together with those reversal moves
and the combat encounters are all
designed to push and pull you around the
environment in a battlefield that's
constantly changing working out how to
use all your different weapons your guns
your melee attacks how to use them all
to your best advantage to control the
chaos and come out Victorious what's
awesome about Gunplay is the variety so
there's six core types of weapon
families we've got assault rifles SMGs
sniper rifles shotguns miniguns and
pistols there's added variety from
weapon manufacturers there's lexcorp
weapons there's gcp weapons there's
armor attack weapons later on in the
game we also have gear sets like gear
sets are villain themed for example if
you have a bane gear set and you trigger
his Buffs in the game some of it will
have the beam drums and you will like
burn and like boom boom boom and then
there's like Green Smoke and you trigger
all kind of effects so you're basically
taking the essence of the villain you're
bringing it into the game
each character has a power level in the
game that we call gear score as you
acquire new gear in the game your gear
score goes up and as that number goes up
it means that you can take how much
harder missions part of this progression
Journey you will unlock more and more
builds more and more ways to customize
your character to really fit the way you
want to play every firearm in our game
is upgradable so in Suicide Squad killer
Justice League you're gonna get lots of
choice to use the weapons that you need
and to complete your missions but most
importantly you will be able to
customize your squad to be whatever you
like you can wear
wherever you want any of the out ER
outfits you can be running
JL outfit and still have like the best
gear score ever I like
our game is a one to four player co-op
experience which means that all the
missions in the game have been designed
to support solo play playing with a
friend two friends or three friends for
the single player fans you can play it
in single player with Bots filling in
the role of the squad so you still feel
like you're part of the team and you can
switch them if you want and try king
shark now or we can say well I think
Harley will be a better fit for this
Mission so I'm going to switch over and
try her out but if you really want to
tear it up going in with a full group of
four lets you experience the full Mayhem
the suicide squad has to offer and you
get to really experience the Dynamics
between how you can all play together in
different play Styles in order to take
on Brainiac and the Justice League
all the fun is right here when the
story's done your experience doesn't end
there Rocksteady will continue its
Legacy of supporting the game after it's
launched we're going to deliver lots of
new content to our players we're going
to have new playable characters new
weapons and New Missions for players who
like to customize their looks we'll
offer a battle pass that only contains
cosmetic items there's just gonna be so
much for the players to enjoy
yeah picture it Harley Quinn kills the
Justice League if you like story games
if you like RPG elements if you like
co-op games if you like customizing your
characters if you want a place a badass
this game kind of has it all it's very
fast paced it's really colorful it's
loud and Unapologetic and in your face
and it's going to be really really fun
don't touch that dial or I'll break your
fingers
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
arrives on PS5 later this year we'll be
back with more announcements soon thanks
for watching
thank you